there's a lot of theories of the gimlet
cocktail a kind of the biggest one that
people talk about it's Thomas G gimlet
he joined the Royal Navy in 1879 he was
a surgeon and the two competing stories
one is that he was encouraging the
sailors to take their their lime juice
rations by mixing it with gin because
they were far more likely to drink
different gin than lime juice um the
other one was that he was trying to
moderate consumption by kind of cutting
the gin with the lime juice in any case
he died in 1943 and by that time the
gimlet cocktail they become very popular
but it didn't mention that in his
obituary and he was also part of a book
called who was who for it was like 1941
to 1952 something like that and they
mentioned him they had a biography of
him and they did not mention this
cocktail so probably not probably not
that's where we got it um really when
you dig into cocktail history there's a
lot of fantastic stories and a lot of
times we don't really know so I spoil
alert we don't really know I'm just
telling you some theories there was also
a tool that kind of looked like a
corkscrew that was used to open up the
containers of lime juice that were on
the ships before roses was was produced
so this would have been lime juice that
was fortified with really funky Jamaican
pot still rum to 15% if you mix that
with gin that's gross so I don't I don't
think that that is that that is it
either um the the Jillette cocktail
Chicago style I really actually like
kind of any mention of this book this is
kind of remarkable this guy Tom Bullock
who is out of st. Louis the first
African American to ever publish a
cocktail book so he was a prominent
bartender in 1917 and st. Louis anyways
he had a Gillett cocktail which was old
Tom gin which was kind of a mild
slightly sweet gin fresh lime juice and
sugar and that's what we call today a
daiquiri right the gimlet being
specifically reserved for Jen with lime
cordial and
but you know Gillette pretty similar
kind of similar and then the in the
subway cocktail book there's two
mentions the gimlet which is very
similar to the to the the Gillette
cocktail except it has soda in it so it
is actually that one doesn't have sugar
so it really is a lime Rickey so you've
got gin you've got lime juice and you've
got soda water and that is traditionally
what what a Rickey is without the
without the sweetener and then they also
do publish a gimlet cocktail so now here
we're seeing there is similar names but
not exactly the same thing and they have
a gimlet and that does specify equal
parts plymouth gin and Rose's lime
cordial first actual printing that we
know of of the real of the true recipe
but obviously in 1930 not the first
occurrence
[Music]